we're following some breaking news at
this hour police say
someone was shot to death near owens and
pickles
orcomano has been at the scene and joins
us now with new details orgo good
evening
christian metro police say a woman was
shot and killed inside her own apartment
here at this complex behind me and now
detectives are searching for the man
responsible police say they responded to
the summerhill apartments
around 6 30 tonight they found a black
woman in her early 30s
suffering from a gunshot wound she was
taken to umc where she was pronounced
dead
metro says a man who was also inside the
apartment shot the woman with the rifle
and then ran
out the door police tell us they're
still trying to figure out a motive to
this murder
when we originally responded there were
people inside the apartment who fled
and we're still trying to piece it all
together so we don't know the
relationship between the male
and the deceased
the metro says they are continuing to
interview witnesses
and look for surveillance footage to
help them find the suspect
of course if you know anything about
what happened you're asked to call
police
or crime stoppers where you can remain
anonymous reporting live tonight orco
mana 8 news now